んふっ　俺は今
とあるアプリを使って金塊を集めている
俺は金塊を集めて
お宝を手に入れるのが、夢だ
さーて、今日も金塊を探しに、歩くか！
ここかぁ
へっへへ
な、なんだここは！なんて数の金塊なんだ！？
これだけ集めれば、、、
億万長者やで！
すごい数の金塊だ！へっ ヘェェェェ
ここか
What?
いやぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
そうか
こいつがこの大量の金の原因,
ヒカキーン！
ンヒンヒンンンン
こいつを捕まえれば、、
大量のお宝が手に入るということか！
キィィンキィィン
あ、
HEY! Wait wait wait!
イイイインンンンンン
Wait wait!
（待て待て！）
Hikakiin
（ヒカキーン？）
Where are you
（どこ行ったねん... ）
Oh-
（あ～…）
Where is Hikakiin
（ヒカキーンはどこだ…）
Hikakiin!
（ヒカキーン！）
Hikakiin?
（ヒカキーン）
あれ？
え、動いてる？
Hikakiiinn!
（ヒカキーーン！！）
キンキンキーン！
はっ
Hikakiiin!
（ヒカキーン！）
キンキンキーン
こっちだな！
あ、あれ？
あれ、どこだ？
キーンキーンキーン☆
いたいたいたぁ！wwwwwwww
キンキンキンキーン！
あれぇ、どこだどこだどこだ？
So fast…
（超はぇぇ…）
キンキンキンキーン
上だな？
あ、
見えるぞ、見えるぞwww
見えるぞ‼‼‼‼
キンキンキン
キンキンキンキンキーン
あぁぁーー！くそっ逃げられた！
っはぁ…速い
はぁ、はぁ、はぁ、はぁ…
いたぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ‼‼‼‼
ヒェェェぇぇぇぇぇ‼‼‼‼
ヒェェェェェェェ！
キェェェェェぇぇ！
キェェェェェぇ！
っはっはww
キェェ！
っはぁはぁ
きぇぇぅぇぇう
クワァ
うわぁ！速い！
So fast
（あいつマジで速いわ）
やぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！ゲット！
キィヤァァァァァァァぁぁぁ‼‼‼
はっはっはっは、
はっはっはっは
キンキーン…(☍﹏⁰)｡
ヒカキーン、ゲットだぜぇぇ！
これでお宝は、俺のもんだぁぁぁぁぁ！
ガシャキーン（レジの音）
これで大量の金が手に入ったぜ、
イィヤッホオォーーウ！
はい、というわけで今回は
キーンをやっていると、
ヒカキーンに会って、
大量のお宝を手に入れたというお話でしたぁぁ！
っしゃぁ
やばい、窒息するかと思った…
はっはっはっは
はい、で、キーンなんですけども、
GPSをオンにして、町とかを歩いていると、
キーンやストーンが手に入ります
キーンをたくさん集めると、
カンキーン！　できて、
それでグッズとかが、手に入ります！
カンキーン（低音ボイス）
うぅ、カンキーン
そしてなんと！今、キーンを集めると、
こちらのですね
サイン入りの、ヒカキンさんのTシャツと
はじめしゃちょーのTシャツが、
当たる応募券にカンキーンできまあす！
イエエエエエエエエエエエエい‼‼‼
イェイ！親分ありがとうございます！
これサインしてますからね、ゴールドでね、ほら
じゃじゃーん
ほんと、キーンなんでね
そぉ、キーンですよ
金で、サインしてあります！
で、これがなんと、50枚、50枚。
の？100マーイ
100枚。　　はい。
ぜひぜひ皆さん、キーンを集めて
応募してみてくださーい！
お願いします！
そしてなんと、キーンなんですけども、
ライフログで、
何歩歩いたかとか、
んなるほどね。
はい。
カロリーをどれだけ消費したかとかがわかるので
なんか、ダイエット用とか
健康的だね。
そしてキーンがですね。
U-FES2017の、キーンブースにありますので
是非皆さん、一度触って遊んでみてくださーい！
そしてキーン、動画概要欄から
ダウンロードできますので、
皆さん是非ダウンロードして遊んでみてください！
というわけで皆さんぜひ！
キーンを集めて、応募してみてくださ～い！
遊んでみてくださいね～
お願いします！
キンキンキンキンキーン
あ、待て待てぇ‼‼
♪ED♪
♪~~~~♪